[Musique]
bonjour question jacob bonjour après une
journée de polémiques jérôme peyrat
investi par la majorité pour les
législatives en dordogne a finalement
retiré sa candidature hier matin ici
même le patron des marcheurs stanislas
guérini l'avait qualifié de néo tom
malgré sa condamnation pour des
violences conjugales il a pris la bonne
décision en se retirant oui je pense
qu'il aurait pas du jeu présentée serait
beaucoup plus simple quelle est la règle
chez vous aux républicains sur les
candidats ou postulants à la députation
qui ont été condamnés par la justice
il n'y a pas de vous les deux de règles
de règle en soi lorsqu'on a été
condamnée qu'on a purgé purger sa peine
on est à jour en quelque sorte ceci
étant lorsque l'on fait de la de la
politique il y à il y a des des
condamnations que l'on traîne et après
c'est une décision individuelle du
candidat et puis du président du du
parti ou du président de la commission
nationale d'investiture qui qui se prend
qui se prend au cas par cas mais je
pense qu'il aurait été plus simple pour
jérôme peyrat de tout simplement ne pas
de candidat de le faire de lui même ça
veut dire que pour vous il ya une
hiérarchie dans les condamnations là le
cas de jérôme peyrat c'était une
condamnation pour violence conjugale
mais vous par exemple si c'est pour
détournement de fonds publics vous dit
bon ça peut passer mais non non je pense
pas d'ailleurs qu'on est de 2,2 candidat
qui soit dans 7 dans cette situation
c'est pas une question de hiérarchie
c'est une question de bon sens
aujourd'hui en examen il ya au moins une
mise en examen dans ces cas là vous
laissez passer
la mx la mise en examen là aussi c'est
de ces natures différentes c'est d'abord
une mesure de protection de l'individu
sais c'est pas une culpabilité
ceci étant ça s'apprécie au cas par cas
mais mais encore une fois c'est bon sens
qui doit prédominer vous savez c'est pas
de s'enfermer dans des règles on le fait
avec bon sens on l'a toujours fait et je
pense que quand effectivement
on est mêlé de près dans une affaire de
justice ou sur une condamnation récente
le mieux ce que les gens ne soient pas
candidat ça évite toute polémique
christian jacob depuis qu'elle a été
nommée première ministre toute la gauche
dit d'une même voix qu'elisabeth borne
est une femme de droite est ce que vous
dit la même chose on va écouter son
parcours j à 100 son passif où sont
passées plutôt pour un passif aussi
d'ailleurs play de plaide pour elle
conseillère de lionel jospin directrice
de cabinet de ségolène royal dans c'est
une vraie marque à gauche et je le dis
d'ailleurs mes amis qui parfois voulu
rejoindre emmanuel emmanuel macron
rentrer dans un gouvernement aujourd'hui
c'est un gouvernement avec une première
premier ministre une première ministre
de gauche clairement affichée ce qui
retient ses qualités mais mais voilà
elle serait partial et moi j'ai un
parcours de 30 en politique tout le
monde connaît mon nom mon bon parcours
il a toujours été sur une même ligne
elle l'a toujours assumé d'ailleurs ses
convictions de gauche mais de réformes
qu'elle a porté depuis qu'elle est
ministre emmanuel macron l'ouverture à
la concurrence de la sncf et la réforme
de l'assurance chômage ça ce sont des
réformes que vous auriez pu porter
défendre enfin sur la sncf on aurait
souhaité que ça aille beaucoup plus loin
parce que c'est quand même une
réformette qui a été fait de la même
façon que sur sur l'assurance chômage on
a fait une demi réformes la révision les
allocations de plus d'un million de
chômeurs
la nécessité aujourd'hui de favoriser le
travail
c'est un titre c'est cela qu'il fallait
faire dans la philosophie oui mais il
fallait aller beaucoup plus loin sur 7
sur cette réforme c'est il faut vraiment
incité
l'assurance chômage et c'est là pour
répondre à des accidents de la vie et
accident professionnel où on se trouve
licenciés en
difficulté on perd son emploi pour
différentes raisons donc c'est un
amortisseur mais qui doit à tout prix
immédiatement redirigé vers le travail
et aujourd'hui je pense que
l'assurance-chômage mérite encore d'être
d'être réformé donc ce jour là il avait
deux bornes là les qualités qui
sollicitent une femme de gauche assumé
qui ne s'est jamais caché christian
jacob vous mettiez en garde tout à
l'heure
vos collègues qui pourraient être
intéressés par
ralliement à emmanuel macron la majorité
n'a pas voulu de mètres de candidat face
au président de votre groupe à
l'assemblée nationale damien abad est ce
que vous êtes certain ce matin que
damien abad ne va pas basculer dans la
majorité c'est une décision qui lui qui
lui revient vous savez on a toujours été
très clair sur ce sujet souvenez vous on
nous annonçait une soixantaine de
députés qui allait rejoindre la majorité
présidentielle à près de 60 on est passé
à 42 40 on est passé à 30 a dit c'est
bon là il y en a trois peut-être que ça
finira 4 ou à 5 ans par les patrons du
groupe oui tout à fait et d'ailleurs il
en est tellement simple été tancé en
réunion de groupe or début de en début
de semaine lundi ou
l'unanimité des parlementaires lui ont
dit de clarifier sa position à vous il
vous dira clairement écoutez on lui a
demandé de le faire immédiatement il a
demandé un délai de 48 heures le délai
48 heures est là maintenant soit il
rejoint la majorité il le dit il assume
il veut rentrer au gouvernement c'est
parce qu'on le veut conduire mais après
s'il souhaite rentrer gouvernement il y
va mais que les choses soient claires ou
alors il reste effectivement sur la
ligne qui est la nôtre mais on ne peut
pas être dans l'ambiguïté sur
l'ambiguïté qu'à ceux des pans hésiter
c'est pas déjà choisir comme souvent que
vous savez il contient doute ce qui a
pas de doute mais c'est sa décision
alors que ça vous dit mais c'est à lui
de prendre sa décision écoutez c'est à
lui de dire s'il a envie de rejoindre la
majorité le gouvernement ou pas mais
vivante et 48 heures samedi bon c'est
vrai que c'était surprenant qu'ils
demandent 48 heures ziza bon genre de
choses on le sait si on a envie d'y
aller ou pas bon maintenant sans doute
qu'ils s'interrogent mais il doit
effectivement dire clairement les choses
aujourd'hui rejoint emmanuel macron il
quittera de fait les républicains oui ce
serait les uns évidence c'est une
évidence et une évidence c'est une
évidence je vous pose la question parce
que nicolas sarkozy lui même a appelé à
un rassemblement avec emmanuel mouret ni
nicolas sarkozy n'est pas ni président
de groupe n'est plus président de deux
parties il est président de la
république ancien prix d'accord mais ça
n'a strictement rien à voir écoutez
permettez moi de ne pas faire de
comparaisons entre 10 à damien abad et
nicolas sarkozy quand même mais nicolas
sarkozy fait encore partie de votre
famille politique après oui il a des
contenus votre camp dit at mais il est
il est adhérent et sa cotisation donc
oui exactement mais il n'a pas soutenu
votre candidat il met d'accord et alors
est une exception se connaissent pas
mais voilà il a été président de la
république c'est je pense qu'il ya
d'autres sujets de préoccupation des
français aujourd'hui vous faites la
partie de ceux qui comme votre numéro 3
aurélien pradié dit il faut tourner la
page aujourd'hui pour la reconstruction
du parti tourner mariage de sarkozy que
la sarkozie était un grand président de
la république je lui ai toujours dit je
les ai toujours toujours défendu j'ai
des relations d'amitié avec avec lui
mais il a fait un choix qui n'est pas le
mien qui dépasse celui de notre famille
politique mais après ils les anciens
présidents de la république celle dont
faire un statut de droit oui voilà côté
encore une fois je pense qu'il ya
d'autres sujets de préoccupation des
français actuel on va revenir et dans un
instant christian jacob vous restez avec
nous au président du parti des
républicains il est 8 heures 40 le fil
info solène cresson
il y à un risque imminent de ruptures
d'accès aux soins et cela risque de
s'aggraver pendant l'été alerte sur
france info rémy salomon président de
conférence des commissions médicale des
chu il estime qu'il manque des dizaines
de milliers de postes de nombreux
services doivent fermer jérôme peyrat
reconnaît ce matin manque d'appréciation
sur sa candidature aux élections
législatives celui qui voulait être
député marcheurs en dordogne renonce car
condamné pour violences conjugales je ne
voulais en aucun cas affaiblir le combat
des violences faites aux femmes at il
déclaré 320 postes supprimés en france
dont une majorité dans le nord le groupe
vallourec se sépare d'une partie de ses
salariés 3000 postes dans le monde le
fabricant de tubes sans soudure
délocalise une partie de sa production
en chine et au brésil ce n'est pas
acceptable réagi le président des hôtes
france xavier bertrand et puis
l'autoroute a7 est totalement rouverte
dans les deux sens entre lyon et valence
après l'accident d'un camion-citerne et
hier matin
franceinfo
le 8 30 france info sabia brasilia marc
fauvelle christian jacob président du
parti des républicains juste avant le
filin font parler des hésitations de
certains à rejoindre emmanuel macron ou
pas si on regarde vos propositions chez
les républicains on a parfois du mal
nous à voir les différences avec celle
de la majorité prenez par exemple
pouvoir d'achat vous vous proposez une
baisse des prix des carburants à la
pompe c'est ce que fait emmanuel macron
non non on va beaucoup plus loin on va
beaucoup plus loin de nous de
redescendre le niveau des carburants à 1
euro 50 c'est à dire en supprimant à la
fois la tva c'est qu'on n'est pas dans
un système de chèques mais de dire on
supprime la taxe sur la taxe vous savez
quand on a un système en france où on
met de la tva sur la taxe intérieure sur
les produits pétroliers
donc on taxe les taxes donc c'est de
supprimer cette cette surtaxe est de
baisser la tipp et la taxe sur les
produits pétroliers pour baisser le prix
des carburants à 1 euro 50 noms mais on
n'est pas du tout vous êtes madame votre
candidate elle-même valérie pécresse qui
disait pendant la campagne
présidentielle mais on est sur le peut
pas agir sur les taxes on est sur le
camra on est sur le programme 2010 on
est sur le programme des législatives il
ya la nécessité d'avoir des mesures de
pouvoir d'achat on n'est pas sur des
mesures qui concernent jll les laits la
métropole on est sur des mesures qui
s'adressent à l'ensemble des français
disent qu'ils ont besoin territoire la
présence et qui ont besoin nord mais
attendait qu'ils ont besoin aujourd'hui
leur voiture pour aller travailler c'est
quelque chose qu'à paris vous ne
connaissez pas mais en france partout
sur le territoire on a besoin de prendre
ça va être quand elle est réelle si on
est bien content que l'on ait la
condamnation aujourd'hui on est sur les
élections législatives c'est une
proposition très concrète de baisser le
prix des carburants en supprimant la
surtaxe on est le pays de l'union
européenne qui taxe le plus les
carburants donc cette mesure c'est une
vraie mesure pouvoir d'achat qui
concerne l'ensemble des français que
vous soyez retraités que vous alliez
travail et que vous alliez faire vos
courses vous avez
assumé pour reprendre la question si
vous allez je suis allez
vous et plus loin que ce qu'a défendu
votre candidate pendant la campagne de
lisa sur la tva non pas qu'ils souffrent
mais moi je le programme a changé ces
points n'ont d'abord cette proposition
était toujours une proposition du parti
ensuite dans le cadre de la
présidentielle candidat reprend un
certain nombre de propositions leur
opinion n'a pas changé voilà là on est
sur les propositions du parti la
nécessité d'une mesure qui s'adresse
encore une fois l'ensemble des français
qui ont besoin de prendre leurs
véhicules chaque jour je vous rappelle
que la génèse des gilets jaunes ce qui
s'est passé c'est devenu des taxes sur
les carburants c'est emmanuel macron
edouard philippe avec un mépris et
condescendance total pour l'ensemble des
territoires ruraux en dix ans peu
importe on peut taxer les carburants
juge qu'on veut aujourd'hui on n'a pas
l'argent pour le faire vous vous dites
si on a la chaleur on a l'argent pour le
faire c'est une mesure pouvoir d'achat
qui est essentiel deuxième exemple
christian jacob quelle est la différence
ou quelles sont les différences entre
l'art et la retraite à 65 ans que vous
défendez et celle d'emmanuel macron bas
d'abord la réforme des modèles mac ont
perdu bien plus tout à vous dire que
c'est parce que ça puisque c'est d'abord
cinq ans d'échec cette réforme souvenez
vous il ya cinq ans il annonçait qu'il
allait faire une réforme extraordinaire
l'équivalent de la création de la
sécurité sociale par le général de
gaulle ah ben on a été loin qu'est ce
qu'il a fait rien pendant les trois ans
l'om dire oui miel qu'ovide je veux bien
une réforme comme celle des retraites
c'est pas en fin de quinquennat c'est en
début de quinquennat en trois ans
incapable de trancher tout simplement
c'est le problème du président de la
république c'est des montagnes de mots
et à chaque fois ce accouche d'une
souris parce qu'à force de vouloir en
donner à tout le monde de ne pas avoir
de vision claire et bien on ne réforme
pas et aujourd'hui expliquer qu'on va
relever les pensions de retraite sans
réformer les retraites c'est se fiche du
monde et se fiche des retraités mais le
point la retraite à 65 ans quand ça
arrivera à l'assemblée vos députés ne
voteront pas attendant qu'un gars de
s'opposer nous nous sommes favorables au
report de l'âge légal parce que on a eu
un allongement de la durée de la vie d'à
peu près 10 ans sur les 30 sur les
trente dernières années et comme on
réforme les retraites il n'y a pas
cinquante solutions soit vous augmenter
les cotisations de ceux qui travaillent
c'est ce qu'elle fait françois hollande
donc à la fois ça plombe la le revenu
des travailleurs
et puis la compétitive des entreprises
soit vous faites ce qu'a fait emmanuel
macron pas ce qu'est ce que d'ailleurs
hallucinant ce qu'il a fait dire que lui
il à baisser les pensions des retraités
il n'a pas fait de réforme parce que
quand on donne un wc il les a pas indexé
n'ont-ils rbc quand vous mettez de la cg
sur les retraités ça s'apaise baisser la
tension donc il a quand même réussi en
cela c'est un vrai champion du monde il
réussit à ne pas baisser les pensions
des retraités et à ne pas faire de
réformes des retraites et donc nous ce
que l'on dit avec cohérence c'est que si
on ne veut pas baisser les pensions des
retraités si on veut augmenter les
petites retraites et pas plomber le
revenu des travailleurs
la seule solution c'est le report de
l'âge légal
mais pardon mais là encore vous dites
comme emmanuel non non non non alors
quel est l'âge d'être écouté ce qu'ils
voient et emmanuel macron ce qu'il y ait
du vent déf du baratin il n'a jamais été
capable de porter une seule réforme
cette réforme des retraites c'est le
seul président de la république depuis
40 ans qui est incapable de faire une
réforme des retraites incapable d'en
cueillir écoutez moi julien qui nous
fasse des discours qu'il veut mais c'est
du vent à chaque fois parce que ils
incapables de faire tant qu'il s'agit
d'être dans le verbe dans les mots dans
les phrases emmanuel macron est là quand
il s'agit de passer à l'acte mais y'a
plus personne dans votre programme
législatif
christian jacob on retrouve aussi la
lutte contre les déserts médicaux vous
dites même c'est l'une des cinq
priorités de notre parti comment vous
faites tout le monde a essayé jusqu'à
présent on n'a pas réussi non il n'y a
pas de solution miracle ça c'est certain
on a essayé beaucoup de beaucoup de
choses
nous une des propositions que l'on fait
moi je l'expérimenté chez moi c'est de
prendre des jeunes internes vous savez
un interne en médecine
il fait son internat souvent dans un chu
dont une grande dans une grande
métropole
il est devient médecin il a 30 ans et
donc à ce moment là bas il établit dans
la vie il vit en couple il ya parfois
des enfants et en lui explique qu'il
faut qu'il aille en zone rurale donc on
le sort d'un cadre qui est le sien donc
l'idée c'est de faire
finir les deux dernières années
d'internât de médecine dans des zones
rurales en médecine en médecine de ville
ce qui permet à ce médecin de développer
une patientèle donc puisque s'il a un
tuteur médecins formateurs ça lui permet
donc d'avoir son propre cabinet de
consultation et donc il découvre ainsi
un certain nombre de territoires ruraux
et de pouvoir s'y installer ça c'est un
des éléments et donc de pouvoir envoyer
effectivement ces jeunes médecins
juniors dont qui n'ont pas encore
terminé leur internat et qui peuvent le
faire en médecine en médecine
obligatoires oui mais on peut le faire
de manière très très incitative après
ccc à voir la manière dont on le monte
on le met en place mais moi je pense que
d'abord sur le plan personnel c'est
formateur il ya la nécessité de
travailler aux côtés de grands
professeurs dans les chu c'est une
évidence mais d'aller faire les deux
dernières interne et d'internât en
médecine de ville je pense que c'est une
bonne chose oui mais moi je
l'expérimenté à provins ç'a permis
l'installation d'un jeune médecin je
pense que non il y en aura une autre
prochainement sont des mesures concrètes
après il ya d'autres d'autres formules
aussi qu'on est testé dans des
départements je pense aux départements
de la saône-et-loire qui ont mis une
forme de dispensaires pour être concret
c'est autre chose il faut pas être dans
le dom mais il faut répondre à ça c'est
ses déserts médicaux aujourd'hui sa
touche toute la france partout on est on
est concerné côté français on sait que
c'est une préoccupation qui vient tout
en sortons d'une homme appuyons nous sur
des expériences de terrain c'est pour ça
voyez que élections législatives nous
nous avons des candidats qui sont qui
ont cet ancrage territorial l'expérience
la saône et loire celle que j'ai mené à
provins et bien des dizaines d'autres
partout en france il faut se nourrir de
sa d'exemples concrets et pas être dans
une technocratie où on rejette à chaque
fois les expériences territoriales le
patron des républicains christian jacob
est l'invité de france info pas trop
pour quelques semaines encore puisque
vous vous apprêtez à l'essai
autre place après les élections
législatives où vous ne serez pas
candidat vous nous direz qui a le profil
idéal pour vous remplacer est ce un
homme et une femme s laurent wauquiez s
qui d'autre savourer de qui d'autre ça
c'est la bonne personne ce sera celle
que les militants voilà c'est la bonne
réponse passagers 8h50 le fil info
servira d'airé comme ça vous pourrez
choisir nouvelle
premier déplacement d'elisabeth baume ce
matin la première ministre va dans les
yvelines en ile-de-france aux mureaux
sur le thème de l'égalité des chances et
de l'émancipation des jeunes filles elle
qui a dédié sa nomination à toutes les
petites filles une première ministre de
gauche clairement affichée dit christian
jacob le patron des républicains sur
france info orpea soupçonné de
surfacturation auprès des fournisseurs
et même de prestations fictives
nouvelles révélations de la cellule
investigation de radio france sur le
leader mondial des maisons de retraite
accusé de mauvais traitements des cadres
touchent aussi des salaires extrêmement
élevé jusqu'à 400 mille euros par an
pénurie de lait pour bébé aux etats unis
le gouvernement décide de mettre en
place un pont aérien pour importer du
lait en poudre de l'étranger 43% des
stocks sont épuisés à cause d'un
problème d'approvisionnement mais aussi
de rappels massifs après un scandale
sanitaire et puis les résultats des
évaluations nationales de miss ep
dévoilé et plus de 80% des élèves
maîtrisent la lecture à voix haute en
mathématiques la résolution des
problèmes est l'épreuve la moins réussie
les écarts se réduisent entre les élèves
scolarisés en réseau d'éducation
prioritaire et les autres
france info
le 8 30 france info sagna bravia marque
slovène question toute simple christian
jacob est ce que laurent wauquiez a le
profil idéal pour vous succéder
écoutez les qualités de laurent wauquiez
sont pas sont pas démontrés il l'a
démontré dans sa dans sa région la
solidité qui était la sienne il ensuite
toutes les qualités la stature etc mais
mais peut y en avoir d'autres aussi dans
notre famille politique et ce sera un
congrès électif mais on n'est pas de ce
temps là vous savez comme disait mon ami
dit drut une après l'autre l'aed
aujourd'hui c'est celle des législatives
mais en tout cas leur objectif est un
candidat sérieux si le chouette oui le
sait pas dit oui ou alors est-ce qu'il
est temps qu'une femme prenne la tête de
votre parti
ils seront candidats ce qui est qui
souhaiteront lettre c'est d'abord leur
envie de l'être avec un projet se
présenter devant les militants mais
c'est pas le sujet du mans moi j'avais
un contrat en quelque sorte lorsque j'ai
pris là lorsque j'étais du président de
notre famille politique j'avais fixé des
objectifs remettre tout le monde autour
de la table rassembler la famille je
pense la dernière présidentielle ça
s'appelle que chez nos corps il ya eu
les municipales ça a très bien marché il
ya eu les départementales ça a très bien
marché que vous un marché après il ya eu
les régionales ça bien marché également
effectivement il ya un échec aux
présidentielles nommé va pas se voiler
la face mais ces législatives c'est pour
ça que c'est important pour nous c'est
des 560 dans dans 577 territoire de
france les français ont choisir celui
qui va ou celle qui vend les représenter
donc pour moi un moment où on connaît
les difficultés que la france connaît en
ce moment on a besoin d'avoir des gens
qui soient en proximité qu'ils soient
ancrés sur le terrain proche des
préoccupations de nos concitoyens et
dans ce cadre là
très objectivement je pense ce sont les
républicains quand le plus de chance et
c'est fermé candidats en lice et combien
si vous êtes
on verra le cédant faire le maximum ce
que je vois plus les gens mais je joue
pas sur le sur les pronostics mais c'est
de dire une chose très claire nos
candidats et on le voit partout sur le
terrain en ce moment les formation les
sondages auxquels vous avez accès aussi
qui nous remontent sur des sondages que
précis c'est à dire quand on l'a le nom
des personnes on voit bien que bien
souvent nos candidats sont allés
meilleure position pour être d'une part
au deuxième tour et pour gagner au
deuxième tour donc il y a aujourd'hui
après ce qui s'est passé aux élections
présidentielles il ya un véritable
rebond des territoires qui est en train
de s'organiser en faveur de nos
candidats parce qu'ils ont cet ancrage
territorial on parlait à l'instant de
laurent wauquiez laurent wauquiez le
patron de la région dit qu'il va couper
les subventions à la ville de grenoble
après le vote de l'autorisation du
burkini dans les piscines privées les
associations des habitants pour une
décision prise par en mer est ce que
c'est la bonne réponse je pense que ce
sera pour les projets qui sont liées qui
sont qui nécessite un partenariat entre
la ville et le et la région mais qui
nous régit rien à voir avec les piscines
sont des projets oui le tueur est
simplement moi je comprends la réaction
de de laurent wauquiez et que je la
soutiens complètement c'est à dire qu'il
ya un moment on ne peut pas tout laisser
faire et et tourner la tête
lorsque vous avez un maire ou en fait en
fait c'est l'alliance des islamo des
islamo gauchistes et des
communautaristes et qui a eu le
temps d'expliquer qui est capable
d'expliquer monsieur piol que c'est pour
la liberté des femmes l'égalité
homme-femme
d'autoriser le burkina dans les piscines
et les 120 m mais dans kent dans quel
monde vit-on mai mais c'est les jeux
d'hier on est dans l'alliance des
communautaristes avec tout ce qui peut y
avoir derrière l' esprit communautariste
et des islamo gauchiste et donc le
président de région réagissent en disant
moi des partenariats avec avec ce maire
aujourd'hui ça pose est finalisé on
verra ça dépend des propositions qui
seront qui seront faits mais il y a des
propositions où je comprends
la réaction de laurent wauquiez se
méfier de deux semaines ou est-ce que
l'on va et comment ça a dérapé de cette
manière là où va s'arrêter monsieur paul
eric ciotti le finaliste de la primaire
des républicains christian jacob demande
une loi en france pour interdire le
burqini est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
voter c'est pas normal puisque vous ne
serez plus déçu c'est sympa une
oui mais je suis d'accord je suis
candidat je suis suppléant et suppléants
pour moi ça veut dire quelque chose c
est très engagé dans la campagne et
croyez moi est ce sur l'autre partie
doit reprendre à son compte cette
proposition je pense qu'on a besoin
d'eux d'affiner parce qu'avec des
dérapages comme celui de pioche il peut
y en avoir d'autres demain il faut
effectivement affiner nos textes de
façon à ce que les maires et la
possibilité lorsqu'ils sont soumis à la
pression alors là c'est encore différent
là c'est lui qui l'initient mais il ya
parfois des maires qui sont soumis à des
pressions d'associations communautaires
qu'ils aient toutes garanties pour se
protéger par là par la loi mais moi ça
me semble invraisemblable dans un pays
laïc comme la france d'autoriser cela
enfin je veux dire son stand sur lequel
baisse cette proposition christian jacob
parce que vous savez que la neutralité
religieuse elle n'est pas imposée aux
usagers dans l'est dans les services
publics alors sur quelle base vous
voulez faire voter cette loi bah écoute
on verra avec avec eric ciotti mais on
avait déjà déposé au moment de la loi
sur le séparatisme aussi bien
l'assemblée c'était un hameau coco sénat
différents amendements qui permettait
effectivement d'éviter cela donc choir
on reprend cette base là soit on en
trouve on trouve une autre mais j'ai dix
ans le dérapage qui alla peut y en avoir
d'autres demain il faut absolument les
empêcher un dernier mot sur la campagne
de valérie pécresse qui n'a pas touché
le remboursement de l'état il lui manque
encore 1 million d'euros sur de l'argent
qu'elle a avancé elle même le parti a
payé 8 millions d'euros est ce que vous
avez donné pour elle d'abord moi tu te
perds sonnerie oui oui bien sûr oui
seigneur significative voulait dire plus
que nicolas sarkozy
que se passera-t-il si significatif si
cette dette reste est ce que le parti
remettra au pot ou est-ce que valérie
pécresse devra éponger avec ses deniers
personnels non nous nous avons le dire
on est autour de 2,8 millions d'euros
maintenant on
le sait non mais c'est beaucoup quand
vous êtes sur une campagne qui à peu
près autour de 15 millions 15 millions
d'euros
pas remboursés donc heureusement que
nous avions une situation saine au sein
de notre notre famille politique pour
être capable de faire face à cela et on
a été on est à huit millions d'euros
parce que il n'est pas possible d'aller
d'aller au delà les railleurs il y a eu
des donateurs non mais je pense que
beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs son sont
surpris de cela parce qu'il n'imaginait
pas effectivement d'être qu'elles soient
contraints d'emprunter sur ses deniers
personnels et donc il ya certain nombre
de donateurs et de dons qui continue qui
continuent à arriver bon effectivement
vous mais pour ce qui est la raison de
rendre son don à nicolas sarkozy ses
2000 euros un oui coutu ça c'est
vous la gardez votre chèque oui oui oui
on vous la parole merci beaucoup
christian jacob mais si vous voulez en
faire il est encore temps mais voilà ça
c'est dit christian jacob président des
républicains invité ce matin de france
info merci très bonne journée à vous
merci à vous